you know I've been thinking a lot about
this because we live in Southern
California now yeah I am a bunch of
different cultures here and I find
myself often when I'm referring to
strain when I talk to strangers about my
partner Rebecca I often refer to her as
my wife yeah
and I know you you tend to do the same
thing with Mariah it's it yeah only if I
don't want people to like dig deeper and
what I mean by that is that I just don't
have time to explain no it's not I mean
we're technically partners but we go
number 5 years probably gonna get may
you know it's like going the whole
explanation so yes like to simplify
things I will call her my wife yeah I
ran into someone I was at the Salt Lake
City Airport this past weekend and
someone came up to me and they're like
you look really familiar she's like what
do you do and I'm like oh what do you do
yeah I said what a horrible yeah and and
and and sometimes like if I want to
avoid that question I'll to say I'm a
writer have a nice day at like like
although really like the thing that
broke me of my habit of that is saying
well I'm really passionate about writing
and and to me this is the the sort of
same thing here with with the spouse
thing I we we get into these titles are
important but they're not so important
that we should well it's like it's with
politics you think of someone I'm a
Republican I'm a Democrat I'm a
socialist I'm a libertarian like this is
a set of beliefs or all sometimes a set
of ideologies or whatever but to not
polarize like that like this is a table
that is a label for this I have to label
this thing so we can talk about these
labels are very important to help us
identify whether it's a thing or whether
it's an abstract thing or whether it's a
belief or whether it's a you know a
perspective or whatever it is I mean
labels are very very important I think
we get we get in trouble when we start
to identify with those labels yeah I
mean there's so much weight that they
mean everything the label becomes more
important than the thing itself right
like you know the term minimalism you
know I like to say I'm a minimalist for
a lot of reasons I think that it creates
some conversation I think like you talk
a lot it is kind of the most perfect
word and the most imperfect word right
because it creates a lot of different
reactions when you hear the word
minimalism flailings emotions yeah but
what that does is it creates a
conversation however I wouldn't like
ever just give a response like if
someone gave here here's a present oh
sorry I'm a minimalist wait get out of
here like that would be the wrong way to
introduce minimalism to someone first
off absolutely it would turn them off
from the concept altogether right and
then and then just you know identifying
with the label that way like really I'm
cut like in that situation using the
label to to kind of as a cop-out almost
right yeah right as if it explains
everything and the label doesn't it it
approximates something they are like I
said it is labels are very good to help
us identify ideas and certain things but
yeah there they are that's just that
they help us approximately identify
something but in at the same time rarely
outside of the these four walls in our
podcast studio shout out to the YouTube
audience hello yo what um you know
outside these four walls rarely do you
refer to yourself as a minimalist yeah
or a minimalist you're one of the
minimalist yeah you would call yourself
a minimalist if someone comes to you and
says are you a minimalist you're not
gonna say well I'm let me say yes of
course I am but but it's not it's not
particularly useful all the time however
there are times where it's it's the most
useful label for something and today
when we're talking about these things
I'm going to sort of intentionally sort
of conflate all of these when the the
the catch-all term is sort of
significant other right because that can
mean your wife or husband and it can
mean your boyfriend and girlfriend it
can mean the roommate that you've been
dating for a while it indicates that you
got someone you've got a relationship
with someone that is a romantic
relationship but even that label itself
is is troublesome to me because
significant is important significant
other or romantic relationship the
significant other okay because what even
romantic relationship we could talk
about that but but
the significant other because the person
is other like Rebecca in my life is you
could say the other half or whatever
right but it's also it's more than other
it's a union it's together yeah and so
it's not just other and so there there
are problems with with many of these
labels yeah but I found myself
gravitating more and more toward this
term wife and I think the reason being
yeah
Bex and I aren't married we don't have a
set of religious beliefs that requires
us to be married and that's to cohabit
it's the best response wouldn't people s
like are you gonna get married now we're
probably not gonna get married why not
it's not that religious yeah well in and
then I also have an aversion to
government mandated marriage too because
for so long it's a little government
didn't let certain sets of people get
married because they shared the same
genitalia and it's like well yet you
this these two people have permission
these people don't have permission and
and it's like the government was was the
one mandating who could and could not be
in relationships basically right but
which is weird because who started that
when you think about the beginning the
founding fathers George Washington was
not married according to the government
there was no such thing as government
mandated marriage licenses back then it
was a covenant and so really what we're
talking about here is a covenant or a
commitment to someone else and does that
require a piece of paper
now Ryan you and I are business partners
and I'm sure we have a piece of paper
that signed somewhere and some file
somewhere but that doesn't that that
means far less that I think contracts
are backward-looking right this is
something from Seth Godin he's written
about contracts in fact podcast Sean if
you can find the essay about contract he
talks about contracts versus handshakes
a contract looks back and it says you
know what I've been hurt in the past and
you know what I have been hurt in the
past I had a bad marriage and it was bad
because of me I was the one doing the
hurting in the process I was also
battering myself so I was hurt because
of me I I picked the wrong partner for
me and we picked the wrong partners for
each other we figured that out over time
in fact we're much better off now as
friends and we get along really well and
and so I had a wife and with that
I had a negative connotation with that
for a long time with the term marriage
or with the term wife because I was like
oh this this thing called marriage isn't
gonna work for me and what was I saying
there I was telling myself this thing
called commitment isn't gonna work for
me yeah and that was men that was a that
was there was a certain amount of trauma
involved with that and I didn't realize
it at the time but but I had all these
negative associations not just with the
the union between two people but with
commitment in fact before I met back so
I was pretty sure that I was not going
to be in another long-term relationship
like it just wasn't for me and that
that's difficult to realize but then you
also realize like oh maybe that's
because I've been carrying forward some
unnecessary baggage into my present life
so the contract looks back and it says
well I've been hurt so I'm gonna sign
this contract that doesn't allow this
person to hurt me anymore hmm what a way
to get into a relationship mm-hmm
however a handshake or a commitment
that's what a handshake is right it's a
commitment for the future and and I can
say you know I'm committed to you Ryan
and and our our friendship our business
and and we can shake hands on that we
can hug it out and say I'm committed to
this it doesn't require the piece of
paper the piece of paper itself does not
equal commitment and in fact quite often
the piece of paper gets in the way of
the commitment because we could point
back to that and say it's funny man
because like these questions that we
have coming up on the voicemails it it
actually kind of reaffirmed why I don't
want to get married and I'm not saying
every marriage is like this this is a me
problem yeah so when I when I get when I
was married I found I don't know I just
found it very easy to care less about
the other person because for us to split
up she was really gonna have to go
through a lot of work in order to what
do you mean and the real they'd have to
get a lawyer we'd have to I had to split
everything up I mean it was like this
process of breaking
vasin right and and it's and it's not
like at the time I was married I was
thinking oh she's stuck with me so I
don't have to worry about doing X Y & Z
uh-huh it was this like sub-conscience
complacency that that was seeping in and
and honestly I didn't even know it until
looking back on I was like oh like that
whole like waking up next to someone and
first off feeling like oh god like I
have to be here oh my god like I yeah
I've got to be here and with the
contract we haven't really been getting
along that well but man I can't really
do anything about it well she can't
really do anything about it either so
it's so it's like it becomes this
complacent feeling it's disempowering
yeah I never want to have that again man
and when I and when I think about the
the the questions that are coming up
some of them at least one of them to me
it seems like that might be what's
happening in the relationship where
you've got one person in the
relationship who really really wants to
do X Y & Z and the other person just
isn't having it and if they weren't
married I guarantee it would be a
different conversation if someone came
to you know if that person can't be the
other person said hey I really need this
I need really need X Y & Z to happen
and they weren't married they're gonna
be like oh okay yeah I really like this
person maybe we're heading towards
marriage one day how what can I do right
now to like really secure this
relationship what what happens you know
five years 10 years 15 years of marriage
you know you know I really want x y&z to
happen yeah too bad I mean I see that
you bet we have this yeah I'm sure that
we got this contract I ain't doing that
and if you don't like it then it's gonna
take you a lot of work to get out of
this relationship well that's the what
you said was so profound that with the
have to I can't believe I have to wake
up next as opposed to get to right and
in the the its contract thinking and by
the way you don't have to have the
contract to have contract thinking there
are some people who are in relationships
who aren't married who feel like they
have to be in it for whatever reason I
have to do this and that's not real
commitment no and and I can't tell how
many times I've hear I hear people say
man if I could do it all over again I
just wouldn't get married
I just wouldn't do it I mean I've heard
people say that a lot of times and if
you know for me if I was in a
relationship especially a marriage and I
was thinking that I might have like oh
if I had to redo it I wouldn't get
married what the hell am i doing in that
relationship so so again
marriage there's nothing wrong with it
it's it's a me problem this is not a
marriage problem as much as it's a Ryan
nicodemus problem and I have to live my
life a little bit differently too to
live a meaningful life and and honestly
like to not get married that that is
more meaningful to me waking up choosing
every day to be with someone rather than
having to yeah commitment is really
birthed out of that everyday willingness
to recommit yeah as opposed to like well
yeah we we may by the way you can do
this whether you are married or not
married you're recommit amonth of course
year to each other yeah or you can
choose to say well yeah 17 years ago we
signed this piece of paper so the
question you disaster this all over
again what is a perfect question for
minimalism in general every every one
widget that we buy every place that we
move every every new relationship we
bring into our life if I had to do this
over again
would I and if the answer is no well
then you just found your new direction
in which to travel yeah yeah I think
about Jonathan Franzen
he uses the term spouse equivalent with
his with his significant other and in
Beck says assured me I shouldn't use
that with us so what is that it sounds
so cold right spousal civilians yeah yes
I mean the thing is I found myself
slowly over time retiring this word
partner and and both intentionally but I
found in order to be more communicative
with certain people when I'm having
these conversations it's using the right
verbage it's using the right dialect to
describe what our relationship is like
and our relationship is much more like
gay a marriage than it is a she's not my
girlfriend but I mean I'm approaching 40
years old I'm a bit old to have
girlfriends and
point but it's a lot more than just the
boyfriend-girlfriend she's just a number
man it's just the number yeah talk to my
back yeah that's so funny man I was I
remember when Mariah Nye first started
dating we were having this conversation
because I wasn't comfortable with the
word girlfriend and because you weren't
coming because it signified too much
commitment are up upfront no for exactly
we just said okay I felt too old so uh
because that's the thing too especially
with younger people like I can't really
call him my boyfriend yet or my
girlfriend is dating because I'm
sleeping with other people right so so I
was explaining to Mariah like hey
exactly what you just said about being
told for a girlfriends like I really
don't know what to call it I guess
partner and there was a woman in the
room one of our one of our friends a
friend of Maria's family and she was you
know she's probably 20 years older than
me maybe 15 years older than me and she
was like you know at 30 you find it hard
to you say the word girlfriend she's
like think about it 50 because she was
that you know she dates and stuff she's
like you know 50 I have a hard time
saying boyfriend yeah and it was right
then and there where I'm like actually I
don't care anymore about the word
girlfriend like cuz it's just an age
thing like it's not that's not the big
video but you know at the end of the day
men at the end of the day at the end of
the day I always say at the end of the
day at night good night Maria at the end
of the day that's the end of the day
Mariah good night no man I mean the fact
is is that I will use the word wife when
I don't feel like someone digging deeper
because I just don't have the time or
you know the mental bandwidth to explain
why I'm Ryan I've been partners for five
years but yeah I dude it's they I think
they are just labels dude that's all
they are they're just labels at the end
of the day no don't say it no I think I
think where where I'm at with this is
what's appropriate not just for me but
for the situation right and talking
about these things and in really what's
important is not the label itself you
know I call Rebecca Rebecca
in fact I'm probably the only person who
calls her Rebecca you know everyone else
calls her back sir
and and that's the label I give her most
of the time it's just back so Rebecca
and and and for me that's an appropriate
label but what is really important here
is not the label you can set those aside
whatever you're comfortable with use
that label and forget what other people
have have to say about it what is
important is your willingness to be
supportive to be caring to be loving to
be understanding and to show that person
how they want to be shown love yeah and
and if you can do that then regardless
of whether or not you're married or
you've just been dating for a week you
have found this partner the significant
other this lover this person in your
life who who is someone you want to love
and the labels are just just that their
labels
you